A menudo me preguntan la diferencia entre mi trabajo
y el del típico planificador estratégico del Pentágono.
Y la respuesta que me gusta dar es
que ellos típicamente piensan en el futuro de las guerras
dentro del contexto de la guerra.
Y lo que yo llevo haciendo durante 15 años
(y me ha tomado casi 14 de ellos darme cuenta)
es pensar en el futuro de las guerras en el contexto de todo lo demás.
Entonces tiendo a especializarme en el escenario entre la guerra y la paz.
El material que voy a mostrarles es una idea para un libro.
Bueno, muchas ideas.
Es la que en este momento me lleva por el mundo
interactuando bastante con ejércitos extranjeros.
El material se generó durante dos años de trabajo que hice
para el Secretario de Defensa,
imaginando una nueva gran estrategia nacional
para Estados Unidos.
Voy a presentar un problema
e intentaré darles una respuesta.
Esta es mi estupidez favorita del Pentágono de los 90s;
la teoría de las estrategias asimétricas anti-acceso y de negación de área.
¿Por qué la llamamos así?
Porque tiene todas esas iniciales repetidas, supongo.
Este es un trabalenguas para decir que
si EE.UU. lucha contra a- lguien vamos a ser enormes
y ellos pequeños.
Y si ellos intentan pelear en el sentido tradicional y directo
les patearemos el trasero;
que es por lo que ya nadie trata de hacerlo.
Conocí al último General de la Fuerza Aérea responsable por
derribar un avión enemigo en combate.
Hoy es un general de una estrella.
Así de lejanos estamos de enfrentarnos a una fuerza aérea
dispuesta a volar contra nosotros.
Y esa capacidad abrumadora crea problemas:
la Casa Blanca los llam- a "éxitos catastróficos".
(Risas)
Y estamos tratando de solucionarlo,
porque es una capacidad extraordinaria.
La pregunta es: ¿Qué de bueno se puede hacer con eso?
¿Ok?
La teoría de las estrategias asimétricas anti-acceso y de negación de área
(un trabalenguas que le vendemos al Congreso,
porque si sólo les dijéramos que podemos patearle el culo a cualquiera
no nos comprarían todo lo que queremos.)
Entonces decimos: estrategias asimétricas anti-acceso de negación de área
y sus ojos se apagan.
(Risas)
Y nos dicen: "¿Lo vas a construir en mi distrito?"
(Aplausos)
Es mi parodia y no es tanto tampoco.
Hablemos del espacio de batalla,
no sé, el estrecho de Taiwán en 2025.
Hablemos de un enemigo contenido dentro de ese espacio.
No sé, la tropa del millón de buzos.
(Risas)
EE.UU. debe tener acceso a ese espacio instantáneamente.
Usan estrategias asimétricas anti-acceso de negación de áreas.
Como una banana en la pista de aterrizaje.
(Risas)
Caballos troyanos en nuestras redes electrónicas
instantáneamente revelan todas nuestras debilidades.
Decimos "China, es tuyo".
Enfoque de Prometeo, una definición geográfica,
enfocarse casi exclusivamente en el inicio del conflicto.
Enviamos un equipo para el primer período
en una liga que insiste en puntuar hasta el final del juego.
Ese es el problema.
Podemos aumentar la puntuación contra cualquiera
y luego terminar con el culo pateado en la segunda mitad;
lo que llaman guerra de cuarta generación.
Así es como yo prefiero describirlo:
No existe un espacio de batalla que el ejército de EE.UU. no pueda acceder.
Decían que no podríamos en Afganistán y lo hicimos fácilmente.
Decían que no podríamos con Irak.
Lo hicimos con 150 bajas en seis semanas.
Lo hicimos tan rápido que no estábamos preparados para su caída.
No hay nadie al cual no podamos vencer.
La pregunta es: ¿qué hacer con ese poder?
No hay problema en acceder a los espacios de batalla.
Lo que se nos hace difícil es acceder al espacio de transición
que naturalmente debe seguirle
y crear el espacio de paz que nos permita terminar.
El problema es que el Departamento de Defensa
te destruye.
El Departamento de Estado por acá dice:
"Vamos, chico, puedes hacerlo".
Y ese pobre país salta por el precipicio,
hace como en los dibujos animados y cae.
(Risas)
No se trata de fuerza abrumadora, sino de fuerza proporcional.
Se trata de tecnologías no letales;
porque si disparas balas reales a una multitud
de mujeres y niños protestando
vas a perder amigos muy rápidamente.
No se trata de proyectar poder, más bien de poder de permanencia;
lo cual implica tener legitimidad con los locales.
¿A quién buscas en este espacio de transición?
Debes crear compañeros internos, buscar compañeros de coalición.
Le pedimos a la India 17 mil tropas de paz.
Conozco a sus líderes; querían proporcionarlos.
Pero nos dijeron: ¿Sabes qué?
En ese espacio de transición ustedes son más jefes que soldados.
No creemos que lo puedan lograr y no vamos a darles
nuestros 17 mil tropas de paz como carne de cañón.
Le pedimos 40 mil a los rusos.
Dijeron que no.
Estuve en China en agosto y les dije:
"Ustedes deberían tener 50 mil tropas de paz en Irak.
Es su petróleo, no el nuestro".
Lo cual es cierto; es SU petróleo.
Y los chinos me dijeron: "Dr. Barnett, tiene toda la razón.
En un mundo perfecto tendríamos 50 mil ahí.
Pero no es un mundo perfecto
y su gobierno no está ayudándonos a lograrlo".
Pero tenemos problemas con los resultados.
Francamente, tuvimos suerte al seleccionar la guerra.
Tenemos distintos enemigos entre estos tres.
Y es hora de comenzar a admitir
que no puedes pedirle al mismo chico de 19 años que lo haga todo.
Simplemente es demasiado difícil.
Tenemos una capacidad sin par para combatir.
Todo lo demás no lo hacemos tan bien.
Lo hacemos mejor que nadie y aún así somos espantosos.
Tenemos un Secretario de Guerra brillante.
No tenemos un Secretario de Todo lo Demás.
Porque de tenerlo el tipo aún estaría frente al Senado
testificando por Abu Ghraib.
El problema es que él no existe.
No hay un Secretario de Todo lo Demás.
Creo que tenemos una capacidad sin par para hacer la guerra.
A eso lo llamo Fuerza Leviatán.
Lo que necesitamos es construir una fuerza para todo lo demás:
lo que llamo los Administradores de Sistema.
Pienso que esto representa
la falta de un libro de reglas generales
para procesar estados que quebraron políticamente.
Tenemos uno para procesar estados económicamente quebrados.
Es el Plan de Bancarrota Soberana del FMI, ¿correcto?
Discutimos cada vez que lo usamos.
Argentina acaba de pasar por él, rompió muchas reglas.
Terminaron el proceso, dijimos "está bien, no te preocupes".
Es transparente, entrega algo de certeza y
da la sensación de un resultado positivo.
No tenemos uno para procesar estados políticamente quebrados
que, francamente, todos quieren eliminar.
Como Saddam, Mugabe, Kim Jong-Il;
gente que mata cientos de miles o millones.
Como los 250 mil muertos hasta ahora en Sudán.
¿Cómo se vería un sistema de reglas así?
Voy a distinguir entre lo que llamo
mitad delantera y mitad trasera.
Y digamos que esta línea roja es "misión cumplida".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Lo que tenemos en este momento, en la...
...mitad delantera, es el Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU como gran jurado.
¿Qué pueden hacer?
Te pueden acusar.
Pueden debatirlo, escribirlo en una hoja de papel,
colocarlo en un sobre y mandártelo por correo.
Y decirte en términos directos: "por favor deja de hacer eso".
(Risas)
Con eso obtienen unos 4 millones de muertos en África Central en los 90s.
Obtienen 250 mil muertos en Sudán durante los últimos 15 meses.
Todo el mundo va a tener que responderle a sus nietos algún día
qué hicieron para el holocausto en África.
Y más vale que tengan una respuesta.
No existe nada para convertir esa voluntad en acción.
Lo que sí tenemos es la Fuerza Leviatán de EE.UU. que dice:
"¿Quieres que liquide a ese tipo? Lo eliminaré.
Lo haré el martes. Te costará 20 mil millones de dólares".
(Risas)
Pero este es el trato:
Tan pronto no quede nadie más a quien acribillar
me voy inmediatamente.
Esa es la llamada Doctrina Powell.
Río muy abajo tenemos la Corte Penal Internacional.
Adoran enjuiciarlos; en estos momentos tienen a Milosevic.
¿Qué nos falta?
Un ejecutivo funcional que convierta voluntad en acción.
Como no lo tenemos,
cada vez que lideramos uno de estos esfuerzos,
tenemos que adoptar una mentalidad de amenaza inminente.
No hemos tenido una amenaza inminente desde
la Crisis de los Misiles Cubanos de 1962.
Pero usamos este lenguaje de una era pasada
para asustarnos y así hacer algo
porque es lo que hay que hacer en democracia.
Y si eso no funciona gritamos: "¡Tiene un arma!"
mientras entramos por la fuerza.
(Risas)
Y entonces registramos el cuerpo
y sólo encontramos un encendedor viejo y decimos:
"Dios mío, estaba muy oscuro".
(Risas)
¿Francia, quieres hacerlo?
Francia dice: "No, pero disfrutaré después criticándote".
Lo que necesitamos río abajo es la habilitación de un gran poder;
lo que llamo la Fuerza de Administración de Sistemas.
Debimos tener 250 mil tropas entrando a Irak
detrás de esa Fuerza Leviatán que barrió Bagdad.
¿Qué hubiéramos logrado así?
Cero saqueos, cero desapariciones de militares,
cero desaparición de armas o municiones,
ningún Muqtada al-Sadr (lo haría trizas),
cero insurgencia.
Habla con cualquiera que haya ido en los primeros seis meses.
Tuvimos seis meses para movernos, para terminar el trabajo
y pasamos seis meses sin hacer nada.
Y luego se nos cambiaron de bando.
¿Por qué? Porque simplemente se hartaron.
Vieron lo que le hicimos a Saddam.
Dijeron: "Uds. son tan poderosos, pueden resucitar este país.
Son EE.UU".
Lo que necesitamos es un fondo internacional de reconstrucción.
Gran idea de Sebastian Mallaby del Washington Post.
Basado en el FMI.
En vez de pasar el sombrero cada vez, ¿está bien?
¿Dónde lo vamos a conseguir? Eso es fácil, en el G20.
Revisen su programa desde el 11-S.
Dominado por temas de seguridad.
Van a decidir desde el principio cómo se gastará el dinero.
Igual que en el FMI.
Votas de acuerdo a cuánto dinero pones en el fondo.
Este es mi desafío al Departamento de Defensa:
Deben construir esta fuerza, sembrarla,
seguir a los socios de coalición y crear un modelo exitoso.
Lograrán armar este modelo.
Me dicen que es demasiado difícil.
Pues les mostraré las seis etapas por las que pasamos en los Balcanes.
Lo hicimos como si nada.
Hablo de regularizarlo, de hacerlo transparente.
¿Quieren sacar a Mugabe?
¿Quieren que Kim Jong-Il, quien - ha matado dos millones de personas,
quieren que se vaya?
¿Les gustaría un sistema mejor?
Esto es lo que le importa al ejército.
Han experimentado una crisis de identidad desde la Guerra Fría.
No hablo de la diferencia entre la realidad y el deseo,
cosa que puedo porque no estoy en Washington.
(Risas)
Hablemos de los 90s.
Cae el muro de Berlín, hacemos Tormenta del Desierto.
Empieza a abrirse una brecha entre los militares
que ven un futuro en el que pueden vivir
y aquellos que ven un futuro que les asusta.
Como la comunidad de submarinistas de EE.UU.
que ve desaparecer la marina soviética de un día al otro.
¡Ah!
(Risas)
Entonces empiezan a moverse de la realidad al deseo
y crean su propio y especial lenguaje
para describir su viaje de auto-descubrimiento.
(Risas)
El problema es que necesitas un oponente grande y sexy con quien pelear.
Y si no puedes conseguirlo tienes que crear uno.
China, agigantada, ¡se va a ver muy sexy!
(Risas)
El resto del ejército se arrastró por la mugre
durante los 90s.
Y han desarrollado un término burlón para describirlo:
operaciones militares distintas a la guerra.
¿Quién ingresa al ejército para hacer algo distinto a la guerra?
En realidad la mayoría lo hace.
Jessica Lynch nunca consideró dispararle al enemigo.
La mayoría nunca levanta un rifle.
Sigo diciendo que esto un código del ejército
para decir "no queremos hacerlo".
Pasaron los 90s trabajando en los lugares complejos
entre las partes globalizadas del mundo.
Lo que llamo el núcleo y la brecha.
La administración Clinton no estaba interesada en esto.
Durante 8 años, luego de estropear la relación el primer día
con lo de homosexuales en el ejército,
fue algo brillante.
(Risas)
Así que quedamos solos por ocho años.
¿Y qué hicimos mientras estuvimos solos?
Compramos un ejército y manejamos otro.
Y es como el tipo que va al doctor y dice:
"Doctor, me duele cuando hago esto".
(Risas)
El doctor dice: "Deja de hacerlo, idiota".
Solía dar una charla en el Pentágono a principio de los 90s.
Decía "Están comprando un ejército y manejando otro.
Y eventualmente les va a doler, está mal.
¡Malo Pentágono, malo!"
(Risas)
Y decían: "Dr. Barnett, tiene tanta razón".
"¿Puede regresar el próximo año y recordárnoslo?"
(Risas)
Algunos dicen que el 11-S elimina esta brecha:
sacude a los magos de la transformación a largo plazo
desde su mirada histórica de gran altura,
los arrastra por la mugre y dice: ¿quieres un oponente interconectado?
Tengo uno, está en todos lados, encuéntralo".
Y eleva el MOOTW (como pronunciamos ese acrónimo)
de basura a gran estrategia,
ya que así es como reducirás esa brecha.
Algunos juntan estas dos cosas
y las llaman "imperio", concepto que pienso es muy estúpido.
"Imperio" no trata del cumplimiento de un mínimo de reglas,
lo cual te es imposible, sino de
hacer cumplir un conjunto máximo de reglas.
No es nuestro sistema de gobierno.
Jamás hemos interactuado así con el mundo exterior.
Prefiero la frase Administración de Sistemas.
Aplicamos un conjunto mínimo de reglas
para mantenernos conectados con la economía global.
Sólo hay algunas cosas malas que no puedes hacer.
¿Cómo impacta esto en como pensamos el futuro de la guerra?
Este es un concepto con el cual me satanizan en el Pentágono.
También me hace muy popular.
Todo el mundo tiene una opinión.
Regresando al origen de nuestro país:
históricamente, defensa significaba protección interior.
Seguridad ha significado todo lo demás.
Tenemos definidas en nuestra Constitución
dos fuerzas distintas con dos funciones distintas.
Levanta un ejército cuando lo necesites
y mantén una marina para conectividad cotidiana.
Un Departamento de Guerra, un- Departamento de Todo lo Demás.
Un gran garrote y una batuta.
Una lluvia de golpes
y una fuerza que te conecte.
En 1947 fusionamos estas dos cosas
en el Departamento de Defensa.
Nuestra lógica a largo plazo pasó a ser:
"Estamos en un delicado balance con los soviéticos.
Atacar a EE.UU. es arriesgar la destrucción del mundo".
Unimos la seguridad nacional a la internacional
con una diferencia de como siete minutos.
Hoy, ese dejó de ser nuestro problema.
Pueden matar a tres millones en Chicago mañana
y no iremos a pelear con armas nucleares.
Esa es la parte aterradora.
La pregunta es: ¿Cómo reconectamos la seguridad nacional de EE.UU.
con la seguridad global para hacer al mundo más tranquilo,
y para asimilar y contextualizar nuestro empleo
de fuerza planetaria?
Desde ese momento se ha generado la división que les he descrito.
Hemos hablado de esto
desde el final de la Guerra Fría.
Tengamos un Departamento de Guerra- y un Departamento de Todo lo Demás.
Algunos dicen: "¡Diablos, el 11-S ya lo hizo para ti!".
Ahora tenemos un conflicto local y uno externo.
(Risas)
El Departamento de Seguridad Interior e- stá estratégicamente para sentirse mejor.
Va a ser el Departamento de Agricultura del Siglo 21.
"Oficina de Seguridad del Tránsito": miles parados por ahí.
(Risas)
Yo apoyé la guerra en Irak.
Era un tipo malo con muchos antecedentes.
Tampoco era necesario descubrirlo justo
matando a alguien para arrestarlo.
Sabía que les patearíamos el culo con la Fuerza Leviatán.
Sabía que tendríamos problemas con lo demás.
Pero sé que esta organización no cambia hasta que experimenta el fracaso.
¿Qué quiero decir con estas dos fuerzas?
Esta es la Fuerza Hobbesiana.
Adoro esta fuerza, no quiero verla perderse,
esto más armas nucleares anula la guerra entre grandes potencias.
Este es el ejército que el resto del mundo quiere que construyamos.
Por eso viajo por el mundo hablando con ejércitos extranjeros.
¿Qué significa esto?
Significa que debemos dejar de aparentar
que puedes hacer estas dos cosas muy distintas con el mismo muchacho de 19 años.
Cambiar; mañana, tarde, noche,
mañana, tarde, noche.
Repartiendo ayuda, disparando de vuelta,
repartiendo ayuda, disparando de vuelta.
Es demasiado.
Los muchachos de 19 años se cansan del cambio, ¿sí?
(Risas)
Puedes entrenar a un muchacho de 19 para que haga lo de la izquierda.
Lo de la derecha es más como de un policía de 40 años.
Necesitas experiencia.
¿Qué necesita esto en términos de operaciones?
La regla será esta:
Esa fuerza de Administración de Si- stemas es la que nunca regresa a casa
y hace la mayoría de tu trabajo.
Desatas la Fuerza Leviatán sólo de vez en cuando.
Pero esta es la promesa que haces al público de EE.UU.,
a tu gente, al mundo.
Desatas esa Fuerza Leviatán,
y prometes, garantizas que -inmediatamente- vas a montar
una increíble fuerza de Administración de Sistema.
No planees la guerra a menos que planees ganar la paz.
(Aplausos)
Otra diferencia es que para Leviatán;
los socios tradicionales se parecen a los británicos
y sus antiguas colonias.
(Risas)
Incluyéndonos, les recuerdo.
Para lo otro hay un rango más amplio de socios.
Organizaciones internacionales, no gubernamentales,
organizaciones privadas voluntarias y contratistas.
No te puedes alejar de eso.
La Fuerza Leviatán se basa en operacio- nes conjuntas entre servicios militares.
Eso ya no sirve.
Lo que necesitamos hacer son operaciones entre agencias,
de las que francamente estaba encargada Condoleezza Rice.
Y me sorprendió que nadie le hiciera esa pregunta para su confirmación.
A la Fuerza Leviatán la l- lamo el ejército de tu papá.
Me gustan jóvenes, hombres, solteros y levemente molestos.
(Risas)
A la Fuerza de Administración de Sis- temas la llamo el ejército de tu mamá.
Es todo lo que el ejército del hombre odia.
Mucho más equilibrio de géneros, mayores, educados, casados y con hijos.
La fuerza de la izquierda asciendes o te vas.
La de la derecha te quedas para siempre.
La de la izquierda respeta las restricciones Posse Comitatus
sobre el uso de fuerza dentro de los EE.UU.
La de la derecha las destrozará.
La Guardia Nacional va a ser esto.
La fuerza de la izquierda nunca entra en el ámbito
de la Corte Penal Internacional.
La Fuerza de Administración de Sistemas sí.
Diferentes definiciones de centralización de redes.
Una fuerza las derriba, la otra las construye.
Y debes hacer la guerra de una manera que facilite esto.
¿Necesitamos un presupuesto más grande?
¿Necesitamos reclutamiento obligatorio para lograrlo?
En absoluto.
Los de transformación de asuntos militares me han dicho desde hace años
que se puede hacer más rápido, más barato, más pequeño e igual de mortal.
Yo les digo "Genial, sacaré el presupuesto de Administración de Sistemas de tu dinero".
Este es el punto más importante.
Primero hay que construir la Fuerza de Administración de Sistemas dentro del Ejército.
Pero posteriormente hay que meterle civiles, probablemente dos tercios.
Hacerla inter-agencias, internacionalizarla.
Entonces sí, empieza dentro del Pentágono,
pero con el tiempo cruzará ese río.
(Risas)
He estado en la cima del monte, puedo ver el futuro.
Puede que no lo suficiente como para que lo veamos, pero va a suceder.
Vamos a tener un Departamento de Todo lo Demás
entre la guerra y la paz.
Última lámina.
¿Quién se queda con los niños?
Aquí es cuando los marines de la audiencia se ponen tensos.
(Risas)
Y aquí es cuando piensan en golpearme
después de la charla.
(Risas)
Lean a Max Boon.
Esta es la historia de los marines; guerras y armas pequeñas.
Los marines son como mi West Higland Terrier.
Cada día que se levantan, quieren cavar un hoyo
y quieren matar algo.
(Risas)
No quiero a mis marines repartiendo ayuda,
quiero que sean marines.
Eso evita que la Administración de- Sistemas sea una fuerza de maricas.
Evita que sea las Naciones Unidas.
Si le disparas a esta gente los marines vendrán y te matarán.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Para la Marina; los submarinos van por acá,
los combatientes de superficie están por allá,
y la noticia es que puede que sean así de pequeños.
(Risas)
La llamo la Marina de Nanopárticulas.
Le digo a los oficiales jóvenes que pueden comandar
500 naves en su carrera; la mala noticia es que puede que no estén tripuladas.
Los portaaviones van a ambos lados porque sirven para todo.
Verán el patrón; los aéreos, igual que los portaaviones.
Los blindados van por acá.
Este es el secreto sucio de la Fuerza Aérea,
se puede ganar bombardeando.
Pero necesitas muchos de estos tipos en el terreno para ganar la paz.
Shinseki tenía razón en esa discusión.
Para la fuerza aérea, el transporte estratégico va a ambos lados.
Los bombarderos y cazas van por acá.
El Comando de Operacio- nes Especiales en Tampa:
los que disparan van por acá.
Asuntos Civiles, ese hijo bastardo, va por aquí.
Regresando al Ejército.
El tema de los que disparan y el Comando de Operaciones Especiales;
no tienen descanso, estos tipos siempre están activos.
Ellos llegan, hacen lo suyo y desaparecen.
Ahora me ves, no hables después.
(Risas)
Nunca estuve aquí.
El mundo es mi campo de juegos.
(Risas)
Quiero mantener felices a los que disparan.
Quiero que las reglas sean lo más flexible posible.
Porque cuando prevenimos el asunto en Chicago
con los tres millones de muertos
que pervertiría nuestro sistema político hasta el infinito;
estos son los tipos que los matarán primero.
Así que es mejor dejar que se equivoquen un poco en el camino
a que veamos eso.
Componente de reserva;
los reservistas de la Guardia Nacional - son casi todos Administración de Sistemas.
¿Cómo hacer que trabajen para esta fuerza?
La mayoría de los bomberos lo hacen gratis.
Esto no se trata de dinero.
Se trata de ser directos con estos hombres y mujeres.
El último punto, comunidad de inteligencia;
el músculo y las agencias de defensa van por aquí.
Lo que debería ser la CIA, abierta, analítica, de código abierto
debería venir por aquí.
La información necesaria para hacer esto no es secreta.
No es secreta.
Lean ese gran artículo en The New Yorker
sobre cómo nuestros jóvenes en Irak, de 19 a 25,
se enseñaron entre ellos cómo hacer Administración de Sistemas
en salones de chat por internet.
Les decían: "Al Qaeda podría estar escuchando".
Ellos decían: "Por Dios, ellos ya saben estas cosas".
(Risas)
Toma un regalo con la mano izquierda.
Estas son las gafas de sol que no asustan a la gente, cosas simples.
Censores y transparencia; los costos intrínsecos van a ambos lados.
Gracias.